allez on va dire la boîte à questions à
moi alors là il y en a quelques unes
alors il ya quelqu'un qui me dit dans
combien de temps on va mourir
nous ne vous faites pas de soucis pour
ça et vous vous mourrez quand vous serez
vieux vous avez un avantage on ne pense
pas ça comment le soleil at il existé
l'origine du soleil laurie le soleil est
une c'est une étoile et une étoile comme
toutes les étoiles et le nez elle vit et
hummer
ça veut dire que le soleil un jour il va
s'éteindre
vous faites pas de souci c'est pas
demain il va briller les tables pour
vous j'espère pour mon avenir
alors ya la langue une amie qu'est-ce
que bmb c'est ça c'est ça un b c de
l'air qui passe à travers un orifice
qu'ils sont bêtes à ils sont bêtes c'est
ça c'est de l'air et quand tu dis gère
des aliments d'anthony tester et ça fait
un bruit
exactement comme auquel je fais ça parce
que ben et sa sympathie